I very much care for Corinne you know I
love Corinne very much like my daughters
so what is you intention betrayal I mean
that is Nick getting put on the spot by
Karen's nanny on tonight's episode of
The Bachelor
now Korean as the villain everybody
loves to watch this season but guess who
is back yep
the guy who perfected that role bad boy
chat an easy online learner Xena put
Chad on the spot about his next move
well we have heard that you're in talks
for another season of bachelor in
paradise what's the update there
technically I already agreed to do it
since Chad's disastrous day in paradise
which included drinking fighting and
passing out now you make me want to
throw your ass down life as a lighters
different for the 29 year old Oklahoma
native I actually have only drink twice
this year I don't really do the whole
like blacking out anymore real estate
career is tanked that's gone I guess
people thought I was murdering only
murder everyone here at first it was fun
though so legs on the bad guy okay cool
bad boy that's awesome but I'll tell you
having to explain yourself every day
gets old so why look for love on
paradise again you want to find someone
else on a show because they kind of
understand that world and how to operate
and live in it and what is Chad think
about this season's bachelor Nick to be
honest when I watched the show I don't
really watch it like it's am I supposed
to say it's awesome or something like
it's super boring I hated watching it
personally this year the only reason I
really can make myself watches just cuz
I'm trying to figure out which chicks on
what a lot of people are putting
together you and Corinne yeah are you
interested in that
yeah you talk to her we've heard you
guys if Chad takes a little bit I knew
that because she was the villain y'know
nobody was really gonna be talking about
an issue is probably going through this
all alone and I knew people were just
probably just tearing her down
well for now the lunchmeat loving
weightlifting fanatic is focused on a
new project a diet and fitness website
for women
just cuz 90% of the people that follow
me online or women so I figured might as
well help them are you qualified to give
those fitness plans to women what makes
you have that background I mean I don't
know my abs I guess Chad don't forget to
work on this muscle also
[Music]
you